the near silence and utter wasteland
left behind by this russian invasion is
crushingly complete
this was the cultural center
a place where they celebrated art
creativity and their heritage it was the
proud centerpiece of bishop village
they've salvaged what they can
pitiful remains from decades of
preservation
it is wanton and brutal destruction as
total as it is senseless
bishops only a small community about 35
kilometers west of the capital
but it was in the way of the russian
advance into kiev
the kashtan kindergarten wasn't spared
either one of two schools in the village
which were pulverized
thousands of little ones have been
through here this launch pad into
education
they thought learning to live with a
pandemic was as bad as it could get now
they're just trying to save as much as
they can
hitting the community heart is the
russian military hallmark
it's a tactic repeatedly used in
chechnya and in syria
the russian troops may have stalled but
this is no failure by the aggressors
rather well-used sledgehammer tactics of
bombing into submission and if no
submission then total annihilation
svetlana's been the principal here for
the past two decades
she's put her heart and soul into
building up this seat of learning only
to see it all but leveled in an instant
i'd like for all of this to be sorted
she tells us for there to just be peace
for there to be friendship
this is so very hard for her
it's very difficult when children are
suffering she goes on 135 kids up to
today
she's the custodian of their futures and
she's remembering the ones who've
perished in the war so far she can't
hold back her sobs
they died because these people couldn't
agree
she can hardly talk through her weakness
it's not right children are not guilty
of anything she says
this may not be the swift victory the
russian leader envisaged but he is
tearing down the very fabric of ukraine
bit by bit piece by piece
i've only seen this in the cinema before
he tells us
but this is a real life horror movie and
it isn't going away
the ukrainians may have forced the
russian troops to halt even retreat in
certain areas around the capital their
military carcasses are testament to that
but they want fighter jets tanks and
missiles to take on their russian
invaders with much more pinpoint success
and they're getting increasingly
frustrated at the procrastination by
their western allies
there's still much fighting around the
capitals outskirts and much destruction
in the outlying communities with the
ukrainians appealing directly to the
russian troops carrying out this
devastation
i found these um
these messages which the ukrainians have
left for the russian troops this one
says the blood of ukrainian children
is on your hands a direct message to the
russian troops and this one is a warning
saying that the moment you're only
feeling the strength from one hand just
wait until we start fighting with both
is the implication
in ukraine's main city they're
protecting their monuments and artifacts
mindful that the russian military
machine seems to view everything and
everyone as legitimate targets
and victory and russian eyes may be
synonymous with obliteration
alex crawford sky news keith